to this item that came out from jeff
howell of the athletic yesterday that
the patriots talked to the falcons about
a trade up to number four so the
patriots presumably now that part of it
is supposition the first part's
reporting news talk to the falcons about
trading up to number four and listen i i
i hate to do this but we need the
audience to understand what happens
everybody talks to everybody else about
every possible scenario you have those
conversations doesn't mean you're going
to do it but you don't know that it's
not a possibility until you know what
they'd want and then you factor that in
all right we could go to four here's
what it would cost us we could go to six
here's what it would cost us we could go
to eight here's what it would cost it's
part of your due diligence so just the
fact that they had conversations
isn't significant in and of itself it
would be significant if they had no
conversations at all right
but but the other side of it is this
justin fields to the patriots idea nfl
media was pushing that over the weekend
the patriots possibly trading up
to some level to some number to some
spot to get fields
uh and and i know that you you don't buy
it but it's just a it's a microcosm
of this wildly diverging opinion on
justin field well i think the first
thing is is like i don't really see
anybody reporting it it's just like
thinking tom pellicero did he's reported
it
okay that's the everybody's thinking
likely they're trading up for justin
fields it's all about like a wish
where we're wishing it because we think
he should go there so new england should
be interested in them too and they're
not they're not gonna take justin fields
at four if they are i'll get on here for
a segment and do it with no shirt on
tomorrow all right i'm just saying right
now i will wear my
nose shirt or white my white you know uh
tank top underneath here tomorrow for a
segment all right i don't know what's
more white you're sick it's going to be
close it's going to be close it's going
to blind
be able to even be able to tell that
you're wearing the tank probably not it
might look just like a suntan thing
right like i got burned or something you
know it might be it's going to look like
a reverse farmer tan that's what it's
going to look like let's make sure we
outline the parameters though what
you're saying is if the patriots trade
up to get justin fields right yes what
if he falls to them and they take it i'm
almost i want to i want to go i'll do
that bet too i'll do that bet too justin
fields is not going to the new england
patriots i there's not a team in
football that i know better and i'm not
saying that i have inside information
here i just don't believe that for one
second that that he's their type of
quarterback so that's where i i push
against that a little bit and here mike
here's the other thing too so i got to
give pete credit though before you pivot
yeah he says no shirt no spleen no
service okay i like that i like that we
can put that in the bottom of the screen
tomorrow when i do that uh
but here's like here's the other thing
that i think gets lost in translation
like you brought it up there's
conversations with all these teams
leading up to the draft they all talk to
each other first off when was that call
made that's the first thing i'd like to
know i mean was that call made way back
when before the 49ers traded for mac
jones most people think in league
circles that the patriots were calling
teams in the top five to make a trade up
because they were hot on mack jones the
common thought is that the the 49ers
were scared of them and the carolina
panthers about them taking a mac jones
or one of these quarterbacks and that's
why shanahan and the 49ers moved up so
that that's the first thing i would just
say when was the call made that matters
right but the rest of it seems to me
like
propaganda from either the falcons going
like
hey uh if the patriots like justin feels
hey the rest of you team should too
right trade up here to number four we'd
like to trade down it's either that or
something from justin fields camp but i
just i don't buy it and i haven't seen
any like i said solid reporting even
though you said pelosaro said something
about it i didn't see that
yeah and and that's the thing you never
know who's trying to put the jedi mind
trick on someone else i mean if if your
guy kyle
shanahan yeah if you new to the show the
head coach of the 49ers chris and kyle
are old friends back to their days at
texas but
if kyle shanahan truly believes if he
hears something from someone he trusts
that bill belichick
is sufficiently interested in justin
fields that he's considering
opportunities to trade up does that make
kyle
go back to the cave
last night and re-watch justin field's
film just to make sure he's not missing
something that the greatest coach in the
history of organized sports has spotted
in justin field i don't think so i don't
think it'll do that to a guy like kyle
shanahan is going to be like confident
in his ability and his offensive ability
and his evaluation of quarterbacks and
things like that to where he's just
gonna be like oh okay you know all right
built bill likes him i mean bill likes
them more than i do you know so i i i
don't think so but i do think there's
people in the league that that could
like affect i'm not sure if it would
affect them the night before or two
nights before the draft but if they had
got wind of that as this was going on
yeah i think it would make people go
well let me look again here just to make
sure am i really hearing this right or
you know
does bill see something i don't whenever
new england's involved in any of these
conversations everybody gets tight
because they're like oh gosh they're
they know something we don't just like
usual what do they know and that's what
scares everybody but i just i don't buy
that i don't see that as being a really
a fit with the what the patriots would
like and
really
you know i i am interested to know if if
the the trade rumor is real like as of
right now like are they looking to trade
up to move to number four because this
is the other thing i would say too mike
with the patriots we haven't heard a
rumor from the draft about them in 20
years and all of a sudden the one of the
biggest drafts ever were like oh they're
they're announcing to everybody we're
going to number four for justin fields
like i just have a hard time buying all
of that if they really like justin
fields we wouldn't know
at all that they you wouldn't we'd have
no clue just like free agency we had no
clue they were going to do that new
england keeps everything too close to
the vest nobody knows anything up there
except for bill mr kraft and like one
other guy so nothing gets out so i have
a hard time thinking that's a real rumor
and
what i am is the exact language hang on
hang on because i got two things to say
cool cool one one here's the exact
language of the tweet from tom pelicero
from monday several teams have been
making calls about getting into the top
ten of next week's nfl draft here's an
aside yes that happens duh okay yeah
including the patriots who could have
their eyes on ohio state quarterback
there we go
oh they could could because i like them
um yeah
or or
or someone is pushing it it's part of
the first trading that goes on there's a
lot of horse trading it goes on push
help me out with my guy and i'll make
sure i give you the the heads up on
something that that happens all the time
i don't like it but that's that makes
the world go round yeah business that's
how you get your five-minute heads up so
you can report something before it's
announced
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports